during the Second World War there were
many resistance movements across Europe
who refused to accept their country's
occupations the most famous is of course
the French Resistance but one resistance
movement which doesn't get too much
attention is the Yugoslav one it was a
movement which fought for Yugoslavian
dependents and inflicted major damage on
their occupiers Yugoslavia was also one
of the only nations in the water mostly
liberate themselves this raises the
question why were they so effective in a
twist of events the Yugoslav resistance
was fractured and so to get a better
view of things some backstory is
necessary by the time the war started
Yugoslavia was a relatively new country
having been created after World War one
and the collapse of the austro-hungarian
Empire it was a multi-ethnic Kingdom
whose government was for the most part
dominated by Serbians who were the
largest ethnic group ethnic tensions
were a grave concern to the ruling
government in the monarch King Peter ii
who wasn't of age yet and so Yugoslavia
was governed by a regent Prince Paul
Paul was growing ever more concerned
about Germany and particularly Italy who
had designs on Yugoslavian land and also
had just eaten Albania Paul wanted to
stay neutral and protect Yugoslavian
independence but his government was
largely Pro Ally
by early 1941 the Allies weren't exactly
doing well and so Paul agreed to sign
the tripartite pact but as a neutral
nation the Yugoslav people are many in
the military were fiercely anti German
and so this action was followed by
protests and in late March Paul was
ousted in a coup this coup placed Peter
in charge with an even more Pro British
government in roughly two weeks later
the axis invaded and swiftly conquered
the country
it was then divided between the Axis
powers like this this part here was
called the independent state of Croatia
because it was a puppet state run by
Crowe arts in fact it was run by a
fascist group called the estar J who
probably carried out ethnic cleansing in
its new territories whilst the country
itself had formally surrendered this
didn't mean that everyone who lived
there accepted it so there were two main
groups of resistors the first were the
Chetniks which was the serbian royalist
movement led by drazi Mikhaylovich the
second were the most famous the
partisans who were a multi-ethnic
communist movement that by Joseph
brought Tito which was founded after
Germany invaded the USSR at first the
two groups work together to sabotage the
axis but ideological differences eroded
away any trust that they had the
Chetniks who were basically the remnants
of the Yugoslav army took the role of
selective collaboration and the plan was
to wait for the Allies to come to their
aid this led to them simply waiting for
the axis to leave and given the
hostility to the
- or them eventually receive material
aid from Italy as for the communist
partisans they'd have sooner died than
collaborate and were based on a corps of
veterans from the Spanish Civil War they
conducted sabotage raided supplies
attack soldiers and routinely liberated
areas from the axis in fact the
partisans were such a problem that the
axis had to maintain over 100,000
soldiers in Yugoslavia to deal with them
resistance continued to grow throughout
the war and in 1943 the Allies
recognized the partisans as the
legitimate resistance and not the
Chetniks by this point the partisans had
over a quarter of a million people in
its service one reason for this was that
it was a Yugoslav movement not a Sur B
one and also because tito gave amnesty
several times to those who had supported
the Chetniks or the axis which boosted
the partisans greatly and this is
ultimately what led to their success the
people of Yugoslavia had disliked the
Germans and the ruling Serbian classes
before the war and the Yugoslav
communists were neva tito was a clever
leader who knew how to get people on
board with the unified vision of the
future
they were also based in the mountainous
regions of Yugoslavia from which they
were extremely hard to dislodge and it
was all of these things combined which
made them so effective and ultimately
led to Yugoslavia being a constant thorn
in the axis side I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to my patreon supporters
which you can see on screen and with an
extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologist Ozark a
flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav Swann
David Silverman spinning three plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston K wood
you